here's a very interesting question what
does pi assume we draw a circle of
radius three centimeters it will look
something like this as we know this red
boundary of the circle will be its
perimeter we have a special name for the
perimeter of a circle it's called the
circumference of the circle but how do
we measure the circumference of the
circle the circumference is round and
the scale we used to measure any length
is straight it's simple we just place
the redline like this like a straight
line and measured this length using a
scale this circumference of this
particular circle will measure
approximately eighteen point eight five
centimeters it means if we draw a circle
of radius three centimeters and measure
its perimeter it will equal 18 point
eight five centimeters let's also note
the diameter of the circle the diameter
of a circle is two times its radius so
the diameter will be 2 multiplied by
three which equals six centimeters for
this circle these are the values we have
for circumference and the diameter now
let's draw a circle of radius four
centimeters this time as well we measure
its circumference this red mark will be
the circumference and to measure it we
make the curved line straight this will
be the length of the boundary for this
circle we get the circumference as
approximately 25 point one centimeters
the diameter will be twice its radius
which equals eight centimeters so we
have the circumference and the diameter
values for each of the circles now
here's the best part if we calculate the
value of circumference by the diameter
in the first case we will come up with
approximately 3.14 what do you think
will be the value of circumference by
diameter in the second case guess
it will be the same approximately 3.14
again no matter which circle you look at
this value of the circumference by the
diameter will always be approximately
equal to this value this value is called
pi remember both these values are
approximations as circumference by
diameter equals pi we can say that the
circumference of a circle equals pi
multiplied by the diameter if we call
the diameter D then the formula can be
written as pi multiplied by D which can
also be written as pi multiplied by 2 R
because the diameter is twice the radius
so the circumference of a circle is
written as 2 PI R this is a very
important formula as it gives you the
value of the circumference even if you
just have the radius of the circle there
is another important thing about this
special constant pi we get the same
value if we divide 22 by 7 so the value
of pi approximately equals 3.14 or 22 by
7
[Music]